yo what's up everybody its prestige i'ma
Luigi here with another Borderlands the
pre-sequel legendary weapon guide today
we're gonna be looking at the X Cala
bastard or where you find it how you get
it and how it is it as a weapon now you
see the name is a pun on the Excalibur
the sword in the stone from Arthurian
legend where the sword and stone and
only the chosen one who becomes king can
pull it out and King Arthur pulls it out
however in this one you were the person
that has to pull it out and you have to
be the most BA you can be be a short for
another word that I think you can think
of now it is a legendary Hyperion laser
it is a freeze laser it has a high
critical hit damage it consumes more
than one item per shot I think it's
always four but I do not know and my
specific one has a 50% melee damage I
don't know if that's universal or not
has a pretty good damage it's a hundred
percent accurate that means it always
goes in a straight line exactly where
you wanted to go it's fire rate is
pretty slow one point one however it's
reloads fleet reload speed is crazy fast
two point five and has a good sized
magazine and it's cryo damage and freeze
champs are both pretty decent so overall
it's a pretty good weapon I don't think
there are any other hidden features that
can be found of this gun I've used it a
little bit and so far it looks just like
a pretty just average good legendary I'm
not gonna say it's amazing but it's
definitely a legendary status and so
it's kind of a different way to get it
than other legendaries so I'm gonna hop
right into that so the first thing
you're gonna want to do is go to
training flats and you're gonna look up
and above the travel station up to the
right and you're gonna find an exit area
to go to a place called Stanton's liver
you're gonna hop in a vehicle and ride
yourself over there when Z up there you
get out of the vehicle hop on a lift and
you'll see the doorway to Stanton's
liver this is where the Excalibur sword
is going to be held it is going to be in
a rock off to the side you'll see up
there where really there's nothing in a
little like island so to say that's
where the X skele bastard is going to be
I'm going to speed it up a little bit
just that we can get to the way the rest
filled up not us be alive never mind
so we're
go kill the enemies right he can't run
past I could run past as they are lower
level than me this is true vault hunter
mode so they just haven't looked it is
don't level a scale level up to me and
you see this person talking thanks for a
quest that I haven't a cyclist that I
haven't done but that's no matter so
you're gonna run over to the rocks you
see that glowing thing in the stone that
is the legendary weapon so you're gonna
hop on the rocks got a jump pack boost a
double jump past them and you're gonna
get 2x kala bastard however you can see
it's in the stone and I can't pull it
I'm clicking II and I'm not able to pull
it I'm not be a enough now the trick to
this is it all depends on your be a
points I'm at 23 94 that is too low that
is not enough be a points to get it you
need over 2500 VA points once you have
over 2500 be able eyes you can pick it
up at any level and it scales the level
you pick it up as however you can only
pick it up once per character so I would
suggest picking up at 50 I did not pick
it up at 50 because I wanted to do this
video for you guys so you see I went out
I left it did some good to some quests
played the game little bit and now I'm
up above the 2500 ba points I would
suggest the best way to get ba points is
like if your look on your BF once and if
there's a specific one that you're close
to getting try and do that if not kind
of just play through the game since
you'll naturally get them and keep an
eye up for challenges of what to do and
once you get 2500 just can't come back
Titans flat and to stand-ins liver and
you're gonna be able to pull it once you
pull it i would suggest picking it up
fast because it does have the ability to
fall into lava i didn't want to take a
risk so i immediately picked it up and
you see there we have the ex cala
bastard level 37 because i am level 37
and i said it levels straight to you so
now we can get a little gameplay of it
in use i would suggest using it
primarily against a singular foot
enemies not vehicles even though i do
show a little gameplay of me shooting a
vehicle that actually kills the vehicle
pretty quickly so it can be good against
better stuff but especially anything
with a crit it does work better since it
does that have a hundred and ten percent
extra damage and has the ability to free
which will in turn do more damages I
would say this is more of a support
issue legendary because most that's what
most cryo weapons are those cryo weapons
are for you cryo then and then you pull
you switch to your big-boy weapon and
then you just take them out and they
receive extra damage because they're
already frozen cry out however this does
take out I don't know these are lower
levels but this does take them out
quickly even though some other guns I
have will take a good deal longer take
them out and because it is 100% accurate
it is it is easy to even hip fire and
get prints with it if you're good at no
scoping and you see I'm not the best at
no scoping this lunar goo lunar moon
buggy however then so I kill it then I
switch to my use my skill in the next
one and it dies like that we can just
hit firing and the 100% accuracy he came
to play there you saw that when I was
hit by Anders every shot went where my
reticle was exactly so that's gonna be
basically it for the video a little more
gameplay me shootin some guys with it
and it's gonna close it I hope you've
all enjoyed this I hope you guys I wish
you luck in finding your question
finding the Exile bastard and using it
and killing people with it I Pro do
appreciate if you've watched this far
and be on the lookout for more of my
videos for the legendary weapons and
just any legendary in the game like oz
kits or shields or class mods since I
will be planning to do every single
legendary in this game so hey guys
that's about it and please up